I mean probably one of the best things
to do especially for people on YouTube
is to go to all the YouTube gatherings
really like YouTube is very much
centered around it's kinda like who you
know that gets you win it's like what
you know that it keeps you there and it
was great because what the gatherings i
would meet various youtubers and even
want to collab with me or get me shout
outs or I give them shoutouts how I got
my start me on my second episode of
movie buzz Michael Buckley from what the
buck show commented on it it was kind of
a big have inspiration to see was people
who've done a lot kind of inspired me to
do well and he was always a big
supporter my stuff but I think the
number one thing is you have to there's
a lot of interacting and getting
connections and that's kind of what
helped me out big time is like this is
it's very much in the business world
it's the same on making videos on the
internet